- I know, I love this panel today.
Well everybody meet each other.
Dame Helen.
- Yeah. Hi.
- Hi.
- Hi guys.
- Well actually-
- Hey Adam.
- You know Adam.
- Yep. We do.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was like, you know,
'cause of Leighton Meester.
If y'all didn't know, that's his wife.
So y'all know each other from when?
- Gosh, I guess I've known-
- Yeah. When did you guys meet?
- When you did the movie together?
- I guess, Leighton and
I did a movie together,
called "The Roommate,"
when we were like 20,
or I was 20 and we're close age.
So, yeah.
- All right.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- So it's been a while, yeah.
- Adam's put up with a lot of
girl nights. (Adam laughing)
He's put up with a lot
of, he's a good guy.
- [Kelly] You're invited
to the girl nights?
- Yeah, you have some good (indistinct).
- You're there?
- Well, he has to be there
for the children right?
- They come to me and then I just kind of-
- Yeah, you're kind of like,
"Hey, you guys having fun?"
Yeah.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- I love that you go,
they come to me.
- They come to me.
(people laughing)
- It came out in a different
way and it was awesome.
So you have a rule when
working together. What is it?
- Oh, we each have a CBA,
which we can pull at any time
during the record making.
- What's a CBA?
- It's a can't be argued card.
- Can't be argued.
- And we stole it from The
National. It's basically like-
- Can't be argued.
- You can't be argued.
- Oh, can't be argued card.
- You can do this on set too.
I would pull this as an actor too.
- It can be in your contract.
- Yeah.
- Basically a veto?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Or we use it the other way,
opposite of a veto,
where it's like, this
is my can't be argued,
this is my thing that if
you take this away from me,
this is gonna not work for the band.
Like, I need this moment.
Let me have it.
- And you get one?
- You get one.
- Oh, you only get one that's good.
- We each get one.
- Because, you know-
- Per album? Per day?
- Per album.
- One per album.
- Okay.
- I like per day.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- This is my CBA for today.
- Per hour.
- [Kelly] There should be one per day.
- There should. There should.
- Has there ever been one
where the other has been like,
no, really, I don't think
this is a good idea?
Where you really push,
you know, you're like,
come on.
- Oh yeah.
We're usually on the same page
when it comes to joint
decisions, we really are.
I don't know why, but we are.
- Yeah, we are.
- Has someone ever pulled a
card and you've been like, no.
(Kelly laughing)
- You know, the only time-
- That means yes!
(Kelly laughing)
(people chattering)
- You both by the way went,
mm?
(people laughing)
- And we were like,
should we tell the story?
(faintly speaking)
But I do think on this record,
there was one song in
particular that stood out to us
that I knew was like, this
is going on the record.
- Yeah.
- And Aly was like,
I don't know
- I don't know.
- It feels a little bit soft
compared to the other songs.
It's a little more gospel leaning.
But like, we also know that
that's kind of where our roots came from.
So we were like, let's honor this.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But Aly was like, I'm not sure
if it works on this album.
- I don't know,
I was second guessing it.
- I was like, this is my CBA.
- Which every artist does.
- This song is going on it.
- Yeah, everybody does, yeah.
- And thank God because-
- And now, I mean, it makes
sense that it's on the record
and I'm glad that AJ pulled it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Pulled the CBA out.
- Yeah.
- Usually that's how it works.
- But I think all artists
do that.
We second guess things.
- Yeah.
- And you can't ever predict
what people are gonna like anyway,
so you might as well
just pick what you love
and put it out.
- It's so true.
- I wonder if The Beatles
would still have been together
if they had a CBA.
- [Kelly] There you go.
- That is such a great point.
- Great point.
- You know.
- If they had a CBA.
- If The Beatles had a CBA.
- It's a slightly woman thing
of recognizing someone's,
and guys, I'm sorry to be,
you know.
- I agree with you.
- See how womanly I can be.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah, you can, you can.
- They lock horns and if
they had this, you know,
maybe some of the great
bands would still be together
that broke up.
- Well, maybe we're changing
history right here, guys.
- Yes, there you go. You're welcome.
You're welcome
- You're welcome.
Everyone gets a CBA today.
- Yeah. You get a CBA, you get a CBA.
- They're like, okay,
what do I do with this?
- I'm gonna use that with my kids.
But they're not allowed to
have one. (everyone laughing)
I'm just kidding. It's a democracy.
So tell us about this song
you're gonna be performing.
It's called "Blue Dress."
What's this song about?
- Well, when we got in to write
music for this new record,
for whatever reason,
we felt like we were
really connected to like,
old country songs at that moment.
I mean, we always have grown
up listening to country music,
like The Judds and,
you know, Loretta Lynn,
and these great country
artists and these songs
that have this incredible
storytelling behind them.
And we wanted to kind of encapsulate that
within this song.
And you know, we're not legends like them
but, you know-
- No, but that's the-
- They inspire us.
- Yeah. And the storytelling
of those artists you just mentioned too.
- Yeah.
- Love that.
So Aly and AJ have a
surprise for everyone here.
This spring they're
actually headlining a tour
that'll take them to some
of the most amazing venues
in the nation,
like Nashville's Ryman Auditorium.
Oh my God, I love singing there.
Los Angeles, Greek Theater.
What a great place to play.
I love watching a show there too.
And New York's Hammerstein Ballroom.
I love that one as well.
You're playing all the cool places.
- Thanks.
- I love this tour.
- We're really excited for this tour.
- [Kelly] It does matter. The venue.
- It does matter.
- It totally matters.
- I didn't know that when I was younger.
- Neither did we.
- Yeah, and then you learn
like, wait, like the vibe,
the acoustics, it matters.
- It does.
- Do you feel like that
when y'all are on stage
or on set or anything?
The environment really affects you?
- I've never been on stage,
I've never done a play.
- But even on set,
like when you're on set
and you're (indistinct)
and they have this set built out-
- I think the environment,
yeah, the environment obviously.
What goes on outside the set,
you know, the temperature,
the kind of place you're in,
I think can influence your work.
- Location even.
- Yeah, location, you know.
- Yeah, like (indistinct).
- Miserable place but-
- I mean, acting's funny
'cause you've got to shut out
so much, you know?
- Yeah.
- Where even in the best of circumstances-
- You're blocking out so much.
(Helen faintly speaking)
- Yeah.
So it's a little different,
but I suppose the less
you have to shut out,
and especially if you're
doing a longer take,
and sometimes the camera's
far across the street
then it starts to really cook.
- Yeah.
- And most certainly as theater acting,
the venue absolutely counts,
hugely.
- Yeah, I agree.
- The acoustics number one, you know,
but also just the structure
of where the audience are.
- That's where architecture
really does play in.
- You know,
it's incredibly important.
- [Kelly] The acoustics
and how it was built.
- I couldn't agree more with that.
- Yeah. We don't think about that anymore,
but it does play a part.
Well, everyone here will have a chance
to join Aly and AJ on tour
because they are each getting two tickets
to a show of your choice.
(audience screaming)
We are very excited!